belfast vor 21 jahren kam am karfreitag
der frieden nach nordirland
seitdem geht es hier stetig aufwärts
selbst in diesen unruhigen zeiten
attraktionen und die belfaster selbst
ziehen besucher aus aller welt an
wir heißen alle willkommen und man kann
viel spaß haben mit uns in belfast
feiern sie dass der krieg vorbei ist
dass sie sich nicht mehr um religion
streiten sondern über gutes essen reden
rp wurde keine firmen sich nur auf die
coolen viertel konzentriert und auf den
ruhm und dann übersieht man leicht was
für eine merkwürdige statt es immer noch
ist
eine stadt die versucht ihre alten
wunden zu heilen mit kunst gesprächen
und musik
und viel vorfreude auf die zukunft etwas
können ein vorbild sein und der welt
zeigen dass eine stadt die so gespalten
waren wieder zusammenkommen kann
[Musik]
das europa
in keinem anderen hotel westeuropa sind
so viele bomben hochgegangen wie hier
doch es strahlt und jazz und zieht heute
mehr denn je die unterschiedlichsten
gäste an hier versammeln sich die
schickeria von belfast amerikanische
touristen künstler und durstiger der
schriftsteller david ihnen sohn eines
notieren und einer schotten ist
fasziniert von der entwicklung belfast
und seiner überlebenskraft ich finde es
unfassbar dass wir es in belfast bis
hierhin geschafft haben
in den 80er jahren war nordirland doch
ein hoffnungsloser fall geschehen keine
lösung zu geben
mein buch ist eine ode auf die
widerstandsfähigkeit der tiere kennen
hat die grauenvoll lustige geschichte
einer jugend gänge im belfast der 80er
jahre geschrieben wenig politik viel
gewalt und schau ich glaube dass jede
form von rebellion jede politische
radikale bewegung gangstertum einzieht
das ist das kraftvolle und es hat etwas
mit schauspielerei zu tun
der beginn der troubles in irland ging
hand in hand damit dass viele nordiren
zum ersten mal einen fernseher hatten
sie schon und fern und plötzlich wurde
da belfast gezeigt und sie wurden zu
akteuren einer chance das fanden die
jungen leute attraktiv sie waren teil
der aktion da passierte geschichte und
sie waren teil davon und wurden dabei
dokumentiert
das hotel europa war die große bühne 33
mal haben die republikaner versucht
dieses symbol von eleganz und größe
klein zu kriegen
insgesamt 10.000 bomben gingen während
der troubles in nordirland hoch 3600
menschen wurden getötet
am 10 april 1998 unterzeichneten die
parteien der verfeindeten kräfte das
karfreitagsabkommen in belfast
heute ist die grenze zwischen nordirland
und der republik offen
die bürger nordirlands können wählen ob
sie sich als briten oder als ihren
fühlen und ihre reisepässe danach
aufstellen lassen
es ist zwar immer wieder zu
zwischenfällen gekommen
insgesamt aber hat er ausgleich zu einer
befriedung geführt das hotel europa ist
wieder ein heiterer ort dessen
geschichte wie ein böser traum aus einer
anderen zeit scheint auch wenn die
ausgehen autorin von kurzgeschichten
über das belfast von heute ist von jeher
fasziniert von dem hotel wenn die ist
eine freundin von david kennen sie hat
in europa geheiratet
in kiens jüngstem werk spielt ein
missglückter angriff auf das hotel eine
entscheidende rolle
dafür stand dass europa für dich dass du
ihr heiraten
es war für mich das klassische hotel als
ich klein war gehen wir hierher wenn ich
geburtstag hatte es hatte diesen hauch
von luxus
das verrückte ist selbst diejenigen die
das hotel in die luft jagen wollten
liebt es ihren
[Musik]
widersprüche auszuhalten
darin sind sie in bau fast experten
früher waren in der hahnen den wolf
30.000 arbeiter beschäftigt der hier
gebauten titanic ist ein ganzes museum
gewidmet
[Musik]
800.000 menschen besuchen es im jahr
auch weil gleich nebenan
da wo früher die alte werft war die
fantasy fernseh serie game of thrones
gedreht wurde im frühling 2009 10 wird
eine ausstellung zu dem weltweit
erfolgreichen film projekt eröffnet
allein in seiner entstehungsphase hat
game of thrones 300 millionen euro in
die nordirische wirtschaft gepumpt
floriert und die show hier zu haben und
teil dieser veränderung zu sein ist auch
für uns ein wahres vergnügen
ich bin ich in zwei wunderbare
amerikaner hineingelaufen
wie heißt es europa und sie hatten
gerade geheiratet und verbrachten ihre
flitterwochen in belfast weil sie sich
beim game of thrones schauer und
ineinander verliebt hat und deshalb
wollten sie hier ihre flitterwochen
verbringen wer wäre noch vor fünf oder
zehn jahren auf die idee gekommen dass
man nach belfast geht um seinen
honeymoon zu feiern
nicht nur die studios ziehen touristen
an aus der ganzen welt kommen die fans
um die originalschauplätze der serie mit
eigenen füßen zu berühren
von ihm hat selbst als statist bei den
dreharbeiten mit gemacht nun erzählt er
touristen von seinen erlebnissen am set
und begleitet sie an die auch ihnen so
vertrauten landschaften seine heimat die
leute kämen nordirland aus den medien
und denken oder gehen bomben hoch die
stadt brennen es gibt aufstände aber das
ist nicht das land das ich kenne und
liebe das licht auf die dunklen zeiten
unserer geschichte getragen hat war die
bewunderung für die schönheit meines
landes noch schöner finden die gäste die
wildromantische küste eine stunde
nördlich von belfast wenn sie sich an
talent aber selbst in die kostüme der
eisenmänner werfen und ihrer fantasie
freien lauf lassen während sie in der
bilderbuchlandschaft posieren ruft brian
ihnen noch einmal die ereignisse der
zweiten staffel in erinnerung und freut
sich an der begeisterung die er nun mit
seinen gästen teilt man fühlt sich als
wäre man selbst im film es ist so cool
so schön und jeden einzelnen penny wert
sobald man erst mal da ist hat es einen
wirklich um belfast ist sicher großartig
man kann nachts rumlaufen ich liebe das
ich bin allein unterwegs und wenn man
erstmal hier rauskommt dann sieht man
wie schön es ist und die leute sind so
nett und das wetter ist auch super
der tourismus gehört zu den wichtigsten
einkommensquellen für nordirland und
seine knapp zwei millionen einwohner
insgesamt hat die branche im jahr 2018
eine gute milliarde euro in die kassen
gespült tendenz steigend auf etwa 35
millionen euro werden die jährlichen
einnahmen allein durch den hype um die
fernsehserie geschätzt
[Applaus]
uns hat so einen schub gegeben ich
glaube das hat wirklich alle erwartungen
übertroffen
außerdem haben so viele an der serie
mitgearbeitet das war wirklich ein
großer erfolg
ihre geschichte hat die nordiren
erfindungsreich gemacht das bringt sie
nun voran mit dem friedensabkommen kamen
investitionen
viele kleine geschäfte schießen aus dem
boden
beispiel klamotten ganz klar an vielen
stellen herrscht nach wie vor die
trainingshose
da scheint es verwegen belfast und seine
340.000 einwohner als absatzmarkt für
maßschneiderei anzupeilen
doch genau dass wir heute hier lieben
schöne sachen gutes essen schöne
klamotten
hier hat sich wirklich viel getan wir
können sehr kultiviert sein will
geworden zwar schneider ziehen ihrer
mini saville row mitten in der stadt
inzwischen auch für männer
ihr markenzeichen aber sind maßanzüge
für frauen denen sie mut machen will
[Musik]
ich komme aus einer familie stärker frau
und ich verstehe mich selbst als
weiblicher schneider nicht als
schneiderin
während alle anderen in der branche hier
männer ich mag die idee von starken
frauen deswegen habe ich vermutlich auch
selbst angefangen anzüge zu tragen
frauen tun das ja normalerweise nicht es
war eher ein unterbewusstes ding für
mich zu sagen warum eigentlich nicht
warum sollte ich keine krawatte tragen
was ist denn falsch daran
und tatsächlich finde ich männer sollten
kleider tragen dürfen jeden einzelnen
ihrer anzüge macht fischer ganz allein
und in handarbeit kostenpunkt ab 800
euro
ihre kundinnen sind die überwiegend
weiblichen anwälte der stadt und frauen
wien mon ami model und moderatorin die
ihren ersten anzug abholt
[Musik]
die menschen touristen kommen jetzt nach
belfast früher wäre doch niemand zu uns
gekommen
schon gar nicht aus einer anderen kultur
es war alles sehr weiß katholisch oder
protestantisch getauft früher konnte man
ja nicht mal in die stadt gehen ständig
wurde man durchsucht es war eine sehr
bedrückende umgebung für einen teenager
sobald ich konnte bin ich abgehauen
erstmal nach dublin
als ich drei jahre später 21 jahre alt
wurde und zu hause in belfast feiern
wollte durfte keiner meine freunde aus
dublin mich besuchen weil die eltern es
nicht erlaubten es sind ja nur 100
meilen aber sie fanden das zu gefährlich
wegen der ganzen bomben und so die stadt
hat sich wirklich bis zur
unkenntlichkeit verändert früher hätte
hier kein tourist einen fuß hingesetzt
und niemand wäre auf die verwegene idee
gekommen in belfast mit glas zu bauen
nun sind die kuppeln deutliche zeichen
von zukunft glauben
wenn die ersten ist die ganze zeit in
belfast geblieben
ihr blick auf die stadt ist skeptisch
man kann hier viel viel besser leben als
früher aber es ist immer noch ein
komischer ort und wenn man sich nur auf
den boom konzentriert und auf die kohlen
viertel dann übersieht man was für ein
merkwürdiger ort es immer noch ist mit
einer schmerzhaften vergangenheit
der brh exit hat den alten frust
wiederbelebt ungefragt ist die
diskussion aus großbritannien nach
nordirland gekommen plötzlich waren die
alten gräben wieder da 56 prozent eine
mehrheit der notieren hat im referendum
gegen den eu austritt gestimmt aber
während 85 prozent der katholiken in der
eu bleiben wollten waren es nur 40
prozent bei den protestanten
ja ich mache mir sorgen ich glaube sehr
viele leute tun das denn schon ohne den
rexit gibt es hier so viele konflikte
die nie wirklich verschwunden sind
das hier ist eine prekäre ort da wirkt
der praxis sehr beunruhigend die neue
und die alte skepsis sind mit händen zu
greifen in belfast in metten zwar etwa
guckt man immer noch auf die
überwachungskamera bevor der türöffner
gedrückt wird
natürlich werden in zwischen katholiken
und protestanten eingelassen aber hatten
nationalität und identität in den
letzten jahren an bedeutung verloren
stehen sie nun wieder im raum
mir ist dieses ganze konzept von
identität so so fremd ich würde kaum
jeder denken ich bin europäisch irisch
oder nordire
ich denke von mir selbst immer zuerst
als velvet underground fun über die
anderen sachen denke ich überhaupt nur
nach wenn ich mal einen neuen pass
beantragt
der brh exit stellt die frage nach
pässen und zugehörigkeit mit neuer
dringlichkeit die meisten notieren
befürworten drei jahre nach dem
referendum eine enge anbindung an die eu
fast alle lehnen eine harte grenze
zwischen der republik irland und
nordirland ab immer mehr können einem
geeinten irland etwas abgewinnen
und so mancher von denen die genau das
schon immer wollten schöpfen neue
hoffnung
es wird der vereinigung irlands
langfristig helfen
ja klar lasst die ruhig einen harten
dragset machen das bringt die sache doch
nur voran
es wird auf eine harte grenze geben ich
bin ingenieur ich weiß wie man sowas
[Gelächter]
dies ist gespielt und doch kein spaß
viele die hier sind erinnern sich genau
so sah ihre vergangenheit aus militär
mauern zoll kontrolleure an der
nordirischen grenze um zu verhindern
dass es auch ihre zukunft wird sind die
bewohner der grenzgemeinden hier
zusammengekommen mit der schau
protestieren sie gegen den br- exit und
egal ob nord oder süd ob die iren hier
katholisch oder protestantisch sind es
bringt erinnerungen hoch die sie ein für
allemal hinter sich lassen wollten
alles ist so frei geworden in den
letzten jahren so normal wir konnten
durch ganz irland fahren als ob es nie
irgendwelche barrieren gegeben hätte
wenn jetzt die grenze wieder kommt
schleudert uns das hundert jahre zurück
das können die menschen nicht
akzeptieren der friedensprozess hat die
britischen patrouillieren und die
grenzposten verschwinden lassen
mit ihnen verschwanden die symbole der
britischen herrschaft dass die briten
nordirland regieren ist nicht mehr so
wichtig seitdem alle nordiren
einen britischen und einen irischen pass
haben können sich der einen oder anderen
nation zugehörig fühlen dürfen wie sie
wollen und vielleicht das wichtigste
ungehindert miteinander handel treiben
können
für den glaser james dailey gehört
behutsamkeit zum beruf sein unternehmen
fertigt spezial fensterscheiben für
hotels und restaurants an den zarten
aufschwung nordirlands der letzten jahre
hält er in bronze zeiten für sehr
zerbrechlich wenn es eine haar an grenze
kommt dann ist mein unternehmen bald
nicht mehr hier
ich rede da nicht von in zehn jahren ich
rede von zwei jahren nur zehn prozent
seines umsatzes macht daily am sitz
seiner werkstatt in nordirland also im
vereinigten königreich 90 prozent aber
in der republik irland seine kunden
werden also auch nach dem wechsel noch
in der eu seien eher nicht und dann wird
sich das geschäft für ihn kaum lohnen in
unsere materialien im süden ein unsere
glasscheiben etwa die wir hier
verarbeiten
aber weil das über die grenze eingeführt
wird müssten darauf zölle erhoben werden
es wird also toll wenn ich es dann einen
kunden auf der anderen seite der grenze
verkaufe werde ich nochmal zölle zahlen
müssen das wird mich aufträge kosten
[Musik]
wie die große mehrheit nordirischer
unternehmer betrachte daily die notfall
lösung im ausgehandelten braig cit
vertrag den sogenannten bags stop als
einen glücksfall für nordirland
kurzgefasst besagt der dass das
königreich so lange in der zollunion und
nordirland so lange im binnenmarkt
bleibt bis es technische lösungen gibt
die eine physische grenze zur eu
ersetzen können
das mache aus großbritannien einen
vasallenstaat und treibe die teilung des
königreichs voran so schimpfen in london
politiker der konservativen und der
nordirischen die op und verweigerten
ihre zustimmung zum vertrag james dailey
dagegen hält die idee dass mit hilfe der
zollunion die grenze offen bleiben kann
für die einzig ertragbar reform des brh
exit
der backstop ist unsere rettung immerhin
betreiben wir hier ein legales geschäft
und plötzlich sagt england wir wollen
raus wenn sie gehen wollen okay dann
geht aber lasst uns hier in ruhe
wir sind irisch und wollen unser
geschäft ganz normal weiter betreiben
die meisten iren die so nah an der
grünen grenze leben überqueren sie
mehrfach am tag ohne viel darüber
nachzudenken so auch daily heute um mit
hunderten von unternehmern und bürgern
am anti drechsel protest teilzunehmen
nur ein paar kilometer von hier liegt
wohl in point 1979 wurden bei einem
anschlag auf diesen posten 18 britische
soldaten und ein passant getötet
insgesamt starben während der troubles
dem nordirischen bürgerkrieg 3600
menschen
wer hier lebt denkt jetzt an damals
klein war wurde ein kind aus meiner
straße von britischen soldaten
erschossen
er war es 12 wir haben die britischen
soldaten nie als unsere freunde
empfunden hier die britische armee vor
unserem haus wir leben genau hier an der
grenze und meine größte sorge ist dass
es vor unserer tür wieder zu gewalt
kommt in london ist es egal sie machen
sich sorgen um sich selbst um uns die
wir hier jeden tag mit der grenze zu tun
haben werden kümmern die sich nicht mit
dem rexroth die grenze zurück zu kommen
brüssel wird von irland verlangen müssen
die eu außengrenze zu sichern und davon
gehen hier alle aus sobald es wieder
sichtbare zeichen einer grenze gibt
werden auch der ärger und die gewalt
gegen sie zurückkehren
[Musik]
irland steht am anfang des britischen
empire und an seinem ende
die briten haben immer noch nicht
losgelassen es sind immer noch
eineinhalb inseln und diese grenze die
sie nun mit europa haben werden ist
nicht nur symbolisch bedeutend sie ist
eine unmögliche wirklichkeit
es gibt keinen weg aus der situation
ohne die grenze wiedereinzuführen
das ist schließlich das was es bedeutet
europa zu verlassen
das bedeutet eine grenze wieder zu
errichten wie früher schon einmal da
stand michael hughes ist selbst ganz
dicht an der grenze aufgewachsen und
noch vor ende des bürgerkriegs nach
london gezogen
in seinem roman country hat er sich zum
ersten mal mit der gewalt
auseinandergesetzt die seine
jugendprojekte der griechischen elias
folgend berichtet er vom widerstand
eingeschworener ira kämpfer gegen den
friedensprozess mit problem das problem
mit dem waffenstillstand war immer dass
ein kleiner harter kern der
republikanischen bewegung nicht
akzeptieren konnte dass sie nichts
erreicht hatten
das nordirland weiter teil des
königreichs bleiben würde
das 30 40 jahre blutvergießen und pein
umsonst waren 2016 als von bags stop und
neuer gewalt in nordirland noch kaum
jemand sprach nun ist die geschichte
erzählt aus der perspektive derjenigen
die grauenvolles tun dafür verehrt
werden und deshalb nicht aufhören wollen
erschreckend aktuell im april wurde bei
gewaltsamen ausschreitungen in derry die
junge journalistin lehrer erschossen
eine splittergruppe der ira hat den mord
den sie versehentlich nannte zugegeben
zur entschuldigung gab die so genannte
neue in atem jargon bekannt mecki habe
sich auf seiten der feindlichen kräfte
aufgehalten nämlich in der nähe der
britischen polizei situation eine kleine
minderheit ist immer noch frustriert und
dazu kommen junge leute die mit dieser
romantik des krieges aufgewachsen sind
der iaa kämpfer als helden verehrt
und manche junge leute wollen teil
dieser tradition sein des antikolonialen
kampfes der in irland generationen und
jahrhunderte altes natürlich keineswegs
alle jungen leute die 14-jährige
beifahrerin neowin etwa will etwas für
die versöhnung tun
sie tritt damit in die fußstapfen ihres
vaters mark lynas professioneller
graffitikünstler auch er hat damit etwa
in der homies alter angefangen und will
hier nun bei ihrem ersten politischen
wandbild helfen übernimmt ich habe
sozusagen in gute hände gelegt
es ist auch gut für sie es ist schön
wenn im leben einer 14-jährigen etwas
großes des weges kommt und sie dann die
chance hat genau das auf zu kunst ist
etwas worüber kinder in meinem alter
normalerweise nicht viel nachdenken
aber ich glaube es ist gut ihre
aufmerksamkeit darauf zu richten und zu
zeigen dass man andere sachen machen
kann
drogen zu nehmen tochter und vater
nehmen eine leere fläche an der
friedensmarsch entrup erfasst in angriff
noch immer trennen 100 mauern und zäune
die protestantischen viertel von den
katholischen alten erinnerungen wach
wunden offen
es gibt noch viele einseitige mal bilder
auch viele überwachen
kinder die zwischen solchen bildern
aufwachsen müssen automatisch schlecht
über die andere seite denken
das finde ich nicht okay ich versuche
beide seiten zusammenzubringen
früher dienten die mauer bilder den
verfeindeten bevölkerungsgruppen als
propaganda mark war einst vater etwa
wurde noch als protestantischer hält
verewigt ich habe mein ganzes leben
bilder gemalt keine paramilitärischen
davon gab es ja schon so viele das
musste ich nicht auch noch machen
es wurde eine gelegenheit anstatt
politische ideologien oder eine
politische gruppierung wäre es besser
sie für kunst und erziehung zu nutzen
die meisten in belfast ärgern sich über
den dreck sit und noch mehr darüber wie
er gelernt habt wird leoni will die für
das dilemma mit verantwortlichen frauen
als witzfiguren magen
die britische premierministerin theresa
may
umgeben von der vorsitzenden der
demokratischen unionisten arlene foster
und der von zehn fällen wie sherry mag
war der erste protestantische
mauerkünstler der mit katholiken die
kulturen gemeinsam weiter die beiden
männer kennen sich seit 15 jahren mit
ihren bildern wollen sie die alten
gräben zwischen den konfessionen
überwinden aus mauern etwas
zukunftsweisendes machen wenn die mauern
eines tages ein gerissen wären werde ich
es nicht mehr erleben
ich versuche auch nicht die mauern
wegzukriegen dann kann ich ja nichts
mehr gemein
im reißt die mauern in den köpfen ein
natürlich braucht markt die mauern um
sie zu bemalen mauerbilder kunst
überhaupt ist gut um leute in gespräche
hinein zu ziehen sie über sich selbst
nachdenken zu lassen
wenn mark malt reißt die mauern ab dann
meint er die psychologischen mauern von
denen haben wir noch viele sowie sich
marx und polen über ihre
religionszugehörigkeit hinweggesetzt
haben und nun gemeinsam an den mauern
arbeiten die sie auseinander halten
sollten so genießen auch die frauen in
den grenzgemeinden die gute neue zeit
von nord und süd sind sie
zusammengekommen um einen teppich zu
nähen der ihre region darstellt einfach
ein fest so etwas gemeinsam
fertigzustellen es macht spaß weil es
ein handwerk ist ein kunstwerk auch und
mir bedeutet es freundschaft es bedeutet
dass wir zusammen gekommen sind es hat
mir große freude gemacht mit den ladies
schon vor dem eu referendum haben sie
geld aus dem eu friedensprojekt dafür
beantragt und 52000 euro bekommen
der teppich in late rim soll zwei mal
sechs meter groß werden in sechs
weiteren counties sitzen ebenfalls
frauen an teppichen jede von ihnen nicht
ein stückchen landschaft und für jede
ist ein anderes thema wichtig ist in der
republik irland verboten und findet
deshalb auch in nordirland nicht statt
der mann darf in einem eu-land nichts
tun was in einem benachbarten eu land
umweltschäden anrichten aus der eu
austritt
dieser schutz weg
rosen erinnert sich an die zeiten als
die grenze noch stand es sind traurige
zeiten dabei und glücklicher glückliche
wenn wir nach nordirland zum einkaufen
gefahren sind butter war dort halb so
teuer wie bei uns also haben die leute
dass sie dauernd rüber geschmuggelt aber
da waren natürlich machen und 2 zoll
posten
ein irischer und ein nordire da musste
man durch man sein zeug ins trockene
gebracht hatte erinnerungsarbeit
gegenwärtige freundschaftspflege und
gespräche über die zukunft das alles
leistet die arbeit an dem teppich auch
wenn der blick nach vorn zunehmend
sorgenvoll ist die gemeinden auf beiden
seiten der grenze haben seit dem
friedensprozess darauf hingearbeitet
wieder zusammen zu wachsen
und dann kam der wechsel stand die
grenze wieder im raum wird das wieder
ein problem ich arbeiten wir daran
gemeinden zusammen zu bringen die am
ende wieder getrennt sein
es würde mich sehr traurig machen wenn
wir wieder eine grenze hätten
das zerstört gemeinden grenzübergänge
machen gemeinschaften kaputt und sind
völlig überflüssig
es wird konflikte geben das kann ich
ihnen versichern ganz bestimmt als
religionskonflikte kinderkanals konflikt
in ihren augen ist der friedensprozess
also noch nicht abgeschlossen
wir haben noch viel versöhnungsarbeit zu
leisten und eine grenze dabei nicht
helfen
[Musik]
die grenze haben sie denn in ihrem
kunstwerk auch absichtlich nicht
abgebildet sondern geflissentlich
ignoriert so wie sie es tun wenn sie
sich inzwischen völlig ungehindert
mitten auf dem grenzstreifen treffen
wir betrachten das hier als unsere
region es ist unsere grenzregion
deswegen wollten wir sie verewigen und
zeigen so sieht die grenze für uns aus
und wir wollen nicht dass uns jemand
sagt wie sie auszusehen hat
schön soll sie sein ihre region und das
ist sie nichts deutet genau an dieser
stelle an der die frauen sich nun nach
belieben treffen darauf hin dass diese
straße vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit
genau hier endete
[Musik]
und so wie in lightroom irland vom
königreich getrennt wurde
so fanden sich dieselben linien in der
hauptstadt nordirlands wieder lange
jahre galt für die jeweils andere seite
in ganzen viertel belfast betreten auf
eigene gefahr
die schenkel road bear fass wohl
berühmteste straße im herzen des
protestantisch kritischen viertels als
katholik hätte man sich hier früher
nicht hin verirrt aber früher gab es in
belfast auch keine sterne köche steven
tauben ist beides und geht auf der
schenkel einkaufen
die julis im jahr 2019 wollte hewing
handeln hier seit mehr als 100 jahren
mit fisch immer nur den besten
die restaurants in denen ich früher
gearbeitet habe wurden alle von walter
beliefert und jetzt kann ich sein fisch
auf meiner karte anbieten das ist irre
genau darum geht es mir es ist family
business wir kennen uns katholiken und
protestanten in belfast so witzeln sie
könnten sich immer noch nicht darauf
einigen wie spät es gerade ist aber
darüber was ein frischer fisch ist lässt
sich nicht streiten
wir denken nicht darüber nach welche
religion jemand hat wir denken immer nur
daran dass wir unseren job machen und
die leute mit fisch versorgen
wie alle unternehmer in nordirland sorgt
auch hewing sich wegen des drecks it wir
sind durch dick und dünn gegangen es war
eine ganz schöne reise wir selbst aber
hatten keine großen probleme
ein paar bomben und so zeug über die ja
jetzt aber schauen alle nach vorne und
hoffen dass die dinge sich beruhigen
exit ist wohl das nächste worüber wir
uns sorgen machen müssen aber
hoffentlich betrifft uns das nicht zu
sehr weil der großteil unserer ware
lokal gefischt werden
ein paar sachen kommen von außerhalb
brasse thunfisch mal schauen ob sie uns
dafür jetzt mehr berechnet
man braucht für heute noch gut wann
immer es geht kocht er mit lokalen
produkten und beweist so dass bei fast
wo früher stud hi und porridge regierten
nun ein ort ist an dem man die besten
zutaten bekommt es hat sich total
geändert jetzt kann man hier irischen
spargel bekommen in kleinen mengen
jedenfalls früher gab es nur ganz banal
ist wurzeln immer so cool aber jetzt
pflanzen die leute ihr eigenes an
topinambur brokkoli sprossen und kunden
blumenkohl romanesco unterschiedlich
gefärbte betet das wird alles lokal
angebaut
früher hätte es dafür einfach keinen
markt gegeben keiner hätte den bauern
gebeten dass anzubauen
jetzt haben die leute so was woanders
gegessen und wollen es hier auch haben
es funktioniert nach dem schneeball
effekt jedes jahr gibt es mehr und neue
frittierte grünalge etwa mit pinzette
angerichtet stevens restaurant es wurde
2015 mit einem michelin stern
ausgezeichnet lange hatten er und sein
team darauf hingearbeitet und doch kam
es dann irgendwie unerwartet es war
verrückt wir hatten zwei jahre auf ich
erinnere mich genau an den tag mein
geschäftspartner hatte die nachricht auf
twitter gesehen und wir haben uns in der
küche umarmt es war völlig irreal wir
haben allen unten ein glas champagner
ausgegeben und im nächsten augenblick
statt und schon fernseh crews vor dem
restaurant
ich wurde für radio-interviews herum
geflogen es war einfach großartig
als der junge steven seine leidenschaft
fürs kochen entdeckte war bei fast noch
ein kriegsschauplatz wie viele andere
verließ er seine heimat ging nach paris
und amerika lernte sein wie tiere in
großen restaurants und kam dann voller
hoffnung zurück der plan ging auf
inzwischen ist sein lokal über wochen im
voraus ausgebucht doch nicht dass wissen
sie in belfast besser als anderswo muss
bleiben wie es ist
belfast an den orden haben gerade
angefangen zu blühen es ging uns besser
und besser wir wurden endlich normal und
jetzt denken wir an einem tag der praxis
kommt und am nächsten denken wir acht
doch nicht nur keiner weiß ist der
praxis bremst uns ab er produziert sehr
viel unsicherheit und die gibt es trotz
allen aufschwungs in der stadt immer
noch im übermaß
nach wie vor ist erfasst eine geteilte
stadt und die mauern sind nicht nur
flächen für kunst am übergang
northumberland rot kommen der omi mark &
poor's unter den neugierigen augen der
touristen langsam voran
[Musik]
die mauern gehören zu den großen
attraktionen belfast eine ganze
industrie hat sich um sie herum
entwickelt auch weil man mit ihrer hilfe
die geschichte der stadt so gut erklären
kann
und wenn die besucher dabei zuschauen
können wie ein neues bild entsteht so
finden sie das natürlich besonders
aufregend sie kommentieren das motiv
verwickeln die maler in gespräche
betrifft denn die neue spaltung durch
den drechselt auch die junge generation
darf ich fragen wie alt sie sind
ich bin 31 durch den dreck sind wird
einfach alles schwieriger für alle
sowohl für großbritannien als auch für
irland
wir sind nur ein beispiel dafür
tatsächlich sollten diese zwei frauen
unser land regieren aber das tun sie
nicht
und theresa may schafft noch nicht mal
großbritannien es ist alles ein witz sei
leoni in die schule muss kann das marler
trio nur am wochenende arbeiten und das
auch nur solange die tore an ihrem
abschnitt der friedens mauer geöffnet
sind
abends werden sie nämlich beschlossen
und zwar von tony robbins kein fan von
wandmalerei das wird schnell deutlich
für toni sind die mauer nicht da um sich
auszutoben er stellt sicher dass sie
ihren ursprünglichen zweck dienen für
ruhe zu sorgen
zwischen den katholischen und der
protestantischen belfaster
und so dreht er seine runden vom
justizministerium bezahlte abend
spaziergänger 2023 das hat die politik
versprochen sondern alle mauern weg sein
doch noch schließt toni haben noch immer
drohen auseinandersetzungen wenn
jugendliche aus den historisch
verfeindeten vierteln aufeinanderstoßen
[Musik]
wir haben keine bomben mehr und keine
schießereien leider sind die mauer noch
da aber so habe ich immerhin einen job
hier erinnert noch vieles an die gewalt
zwei kilometer weiter aber tobt die
party die belfaster feiern auch dass sie
eine zukunft haben
bars und restaurants schießen im viertel
rund um die kathedrale aus dem boden
konzerte überall
[Musik]
toni will jetzt willens treten auf der
bandleader geht als der nordirische bob
dylan musik so sagt er habe auch die
tiefen spaltungen in nordirland schon
immer überwinden können
[Musik]
heute spielt die band im berühmtesten
gefängnis von belfast in der kremlin
roth wurden seit 1846 verbrecher
eingesperrt später auch die kämpfer im
bürgerkrieg inzwischen ist das gefängnis
ein museum und ein ungewöhnlicher
veranstaltungsort man kann etwa das
kombipack buchen konzert plus dinner
es ist wunderbar etwas ganz besonderes
und gar nicht gruselig ich hatte einen
freund der hier in einer der zellen ein
gesessen hat früher war das hier ein
haus des schmerzes nun ist es ein haus
der erkenntnis geworden
beim rundgang durch das gefängnis museum
checken toni und seine willens die
gummizelle
werfen einen betroffenen blick auf den
garten erinnern die letzten hier
gehängten kindermörder und
unabhängigkeitskämpfer die gefühle
schwanken auch bei den rockern zwischen
grauen und erleichterung darüber wie
sehr die zeiten sich geändert haben
na wie lange müsst ihr absitzen öffnet
alte wunden er hat so manchen leuten die
entschuldigung dafür geliefert sehr
hässliche ansichten zu äußern
die gesellschaft ist über diese frage
momentan sehr zerrissen hoffnungsvoll
betrachtet ist es vielleicht genau das
was wir brauchen um uns im spiegel an zu
schauen und uns zu fragen was ist aus
uns geworden und wir wollen wir von hier
aus weiter geht was für eine zukunft
wollen wir für unsere kinder eine
trostlose zerrissene oder wollen wir uns
zusammentun
wir haben schließlich wirklich größere
probleme als den wechsel
toni betrachtet den br- exit als einen
störfaktor in der ansonsten
beispiellosen erfolgsgeschichte erfasst
[Musik]
wir können ein vorbild sein für die welt
und zeigen wie man verwerfung
widerhallen kann hat das ist eine
aufgabe für belfast
die welt ist momentan so zerstritten und
ich glaube wir sollten allen sagen
schaut mal man kann das schaffen wir
konnten das augen
nordirland als eine geschichte die es
wert ist erzählt zu werden
[Musik]
schon immer wurde über diesen teil des
königreichs viel geschrieben nun aber
werden die bücher von jörg david kennen
michael hughes und anderen auch gelesen
gewinnen preise
das zerrissene optimistische und doch
sorgen von der in ihnen trifft den
zeitgeist guten kompromiss erkennt man
immer daran dass alle unglücklich sind
in nordirland ist jeder wirklich
unglücklich politisch das sagt mir es
hat funktioniert das land selbst war ein
kompromiss
es war ein experiment der versuch eine
lösung für ein unlösbares problem zu
finden und es ist gescheitert niemand
findet es gut dass das nordirland gilt
niemand fantasien gut weil es von anfang
an ein kompromiss war aber vielleicht
müssen wir einfach damit leben um
glücklich zu sein
drei tage haben
marc und paul gemalt jetzt sind sie fast
fertig ein neues bild über das die
belfaster sich unterhalten sich streiten
und wieder vertragen können
gemalt von einem jungen gesicht der
stadt die mal bilder bedeuten den
menschen die ich aufgewachsen sind sehr
viel
ohne sie wird ihnen etwas fehlen aber
ich nehme an dass die generation nach
mir etwas anderes tun wird um
herauszufinden wer sie sind
verfasst hat es weit gebracht in den
letzten zwei jahrzehnten die bewohner
der stadt genießen die gute neue zeit
sie sind froh dass endlich alles
friedlich ist und hoffen dass es so
bleibt
[Musik]
[Applaus]